[Music]
this week we've got mistress reveal
Black Panther and twitch upset which
upset I like mystery revealed
mister even better tell me the detail
so this mafioso name's Joe skinny
merlina that's not a real name Joe
skinny Marley no yes sounds like a movie
he's on trial for federal racketeering
damn uh [ __ ] still exists what does that
racketeering just means like illicit
business ventures I think yeah cuz I was
like what is what is the racketeering
cry like what is racketeering but it's
kind of like sounds like a party to me
you have a bunch of different legal
business here illegal illegal ways of
making money okay so skinny skinny here
he's on trial and why he was on trial
one of like the mafioso snitches he
testified like it kind of like slipped
out that he was sleeping with this rep
that was involved in the in the whole
case here and so the wife of skinny
Deborah she that's when she found out
that her husband had a mistress
well this niche was like accidentally it
expelled the beam a mistress is someone
they have like a relationship with her a
minute
okay this is not the norm I thought
every Mafia's wife would know that her
man is bangin hella girls every single
night time I've seen God for Sopranos
that's how it is in every movie is
fellas yeah yeah but no one ever thinks
that happens to them really loves me I
changed him well it's kind of funny or I
don't know funny but Deborah apparently
she previously got like she cheated on
her her husband while he was in jail and
in that time she got pregnant and then
she ended up she ended up going to
Maryland for an abortion or something so
I think they both I don't think I've
ever met a Deborah me neither oh wait
that's my mom Janice oh my god Wow he
looked like he looks like um the
from Seinfeld but then like the gangster
Kramer panono
yeah really Soup Nazi no no he looks
like Kramer and Jerry Seinfeld together
Debra what is she American Asian with
like lipid well she's an Italian girl
with plastic surgery oh yeah they look
Asian I don't know she's probably agent
oh yeah like Donatella Versace what is
that is she a mistress what I see the
wife Oh what did you imagine
um I imagine like more like I picture
mafia like the way it is in the movies
but like a modern version that full just
looks like that's the modern this is the
modern mafia though they change that to
the 90s like I think we're really
wishing for the hey give me your money
for the Godfather not wearing a suit
there's nothing suave about him I just
fell he just looks like a chump off the
street don't kill me don't kill me
[Laughter]
you insult the mob boss yeah just in you
talking about your shoes better than the
real Pablo the real Paul looks like a
geek well that's true I think Deeks make
the best gangsters though so you're
intimidating a person but not in
pictures yeah I think like if you're in
the Mafia you should only be wearing
Nike cuz like you need to be really
nimble and [ __ ] don't you yeah cuz like
the [ __ ] suits are super stiff like
how the [ __ ] are you are only a tech
please you're a mob boss you got your
like minions doing that you're the
minions also wear suits they were track
suits Oh see that make sense you're at
the desk like this counter ready yeah
that's right they're wearing tracksuits
they're all waiting the divas jumpers a
[ __ ] and they're b-boying in [ __ ] pop
and locking
buh-buh-buh-buh come here I love movies
same they're so cool it's fun well which
was the last
like the most recent one the one with a
nice kick ryan gosling it was it was a
failure no black like something
mass black mass with a Johnny Depp I
think oh that was a mafia was it there
was a mafia movie yeah yeah geeky yeah I
forgot about that [ __ ] they're just
making headlines here cuz it was pretty
funny how like she liked Debra's face
the wife as soon as she overheard that
like oh he got caught sleeping with her
that she was just like wait what I got
had no idea he had a mistress just stood
up in the courtroom what the hell did I
just hear i watch Lillehammer Hayley
hammer no it's you know the characters
sail from Sopranos the guy with the hair
that's like mine oh yeah
he has his own spin-off show with it's
like being a gangster that for good for
witness protection or whatever he goes
to Norway and it's like what do you do
what happens when you put a Italian
mobster from New York in the middle of
this safe little Norway town and it's
pretty it's a really funny comedy you
guys like Goodfellas or Godfather this
is the [ __ ] [ __ ] what our generation
I think if you ask the older people
don't be like Godfather I know I watch
both though so it's a [ __ ] classic
yeah good boat I don't know the
references but I've never seen the movie
I only know the references because in
the Animaniacs the pigeons were like in
person
goodfeathers I sometimes wish I was
Italian
I always Michelle I like spaghetti oh
you're American then okay that's true I
don't eat real Italian food but it's
like I I watched these movies and I'm I
I want to own a casino in the 1940s in
Las Vegas and like wear suits all day
and then like I don't know grab people
shake them and like a slap them around
hey I mean I've seen that one video with
that one italian old lady as she was
talking to the google home [ __ ] shit's
[ __ ] hilarious dude it's because like
old people when they talk to like these
like new technology [ __ ] they never get
the name right so like for example if
it's like a lesson like Odessa
no it's Alexa but she would shoot she
was calling like a Google googoo so
she's like old people always [ __ ] up the
days for some reason
hey sera sera like no Siri come on all
right Sarah
but that Google thing cracked me the
[ __ ] up so how's it it's magic
it's sorcery yeah all this [ __ ] that's
gonna be us
I know what I want if I do I'm gonna be
cool grandpa I can't wait til I'm hella
old and I'm looking at my phone screen
like this that's why we keep having to
collab on YouTube just so we can stay in
with the know and so okay it's lit yeah
yeah that's the joke that what that was
not cool
my dad looks like his phone like he's
staring at the sudden [ __ ] go to the
nukes and they had their glasses and
they pucker their lips yeah well they
did this so my mom isn't a lot it's like
this to hold it up I can't wait til I do
that [ __ ] to fry night story have you
guys are you guys excited for Black
Panther I don't really know that
character that one either what everyone
keeps saying that it's sick next level
nothing's been done this way is it Idris
Elba yes I'm a big fan of him I like him
I'll show you guys quoi yeah here you go
hey wha he's coming my son it is your
time
the black panther lives
but you can't bring the joke ten the
world's gonna start over
[Music]
30p energy get tickets now that's tight
oh yeah people say it's like one of the
dopest Marvel films out yet yeah
it currently has 100% around tomato
after the first 50 review something went
up by is it out woman and Captain
America they were also a 100 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes when it first came out
but then after like the public saw it
they went down to like 91 but wonder was
Wonder Woman was wack just what's really
I don't even like comic book movies but
I like I thought Wonder Woman was mad I
liked Wonder Woman you know like what
was corny about it it's just like it but
she was so grounded and real like I like
that's my legs about it there was just
one scene that it just looked like a
Maybelline commercial but I thought it
was really stupid she's fighting with it
was when they were in like the dugout
and then watching Wonder Woman I've
never seen a woman yeah roll like that
no like see but see but this is what I'm
talking about people are talking about
the film in that type of it like a
personal thing as a woman thing
onee-sama has a film I thought it was
[ __ ] wack it was great usually like
on the side of like oh like I need a
woman to empower me or whatever like
like when I'm watching a movie but yeah
it was the same it took me by surprise
how affected I was by it because
afterwards I like felt like I could do
something like it's I'm just talking
about well I'm just not seeing it as a
film it was like Dori suck for you
this acting or the
I mean the acting was cool whatever okay
what's your favorite superhero movie
mine yeah it would be guardians of the
galaxy the mission that's a good one too
but like
that was like because there was a group
of misfits and so like everyone related
exactly but like what stick your
favorite like hero like you know
Superman
Iron Man cuz all of those to me like
those are all cheesy plots like yeah
okay okay so you know so you put Wonder
Woman in like the same category same
thing as those things I thought Wonder
Woman was better than any of the other
ones like Civil War was really good
though yeah actually yeah Civil War was
good I like that Deadpool is really
funny he's my favorite but it's always
these films that like in terms of like
Marvel films and my fan fiction films
it's hard for somebody who isn't really
into it to really like these films
because they're kind of basing it off of
nostalgia so like when you bring into
these films and you don't build a world
for them like there's no explanation for
anything so when I watch it like yeah I
like comic books but I didn't know too
much about anything so that's why Black
Panther guards of the galaxy they don't
really have a huge fandom so they allow
it to breathe as a film oh that's true
because you don't have any pre biases
about it but you're a big year but the
reason why you said you like you walked
out at yourself in power so that's your
connection and it wasn't it wasn't just
they should well she was a woman but
also like growing up as a kid I never
saw like brown woman like I never saw
like there were like there wasn't really
a brown it's ethnic women yeah like
people darker toned women like no one
looked like me on the other one was the
first one Dan was her name I forgot like
in the 60s so what I'm saying like the
things that you're taking away from it
like me yeah I can't take away from you
so for me it's like the same as any Iron
Man that came out Spider Man I never
liked any of those films did you like
Logan I liked Logan was dope
Logan was [ __ ] in Sowers there was
more blood and more yes they did like a
film noir version of it even better dude
I [ __ ] loved it when I watched Wonder
Woman I was like oh man it would be so
awesome to be rescued and protected by
them and then like instead of like you
know how in the movies there's always a
guy holding a damsel in distress I wanna
be the man in distress me
like that I was like that's awesome we
want to be the Steve yeah I want to be
the the main love interest yeah they'll
be so cool they got a bunch of you're
seeing about a bunch of CrossFitters
right like crossfitter chicks yeah they
were jacked so that the girls can fit
the rule so it's not a bunch like flimsy
looking girls trying to do martial arts
or actual strong girls but strong and
sexy it was a great time there were a
hundred and twenty fifth to eighth grade
students that celebrated the muse of the
fact that they're gonna all get to go
see Black Panther and so I'm gonna show
you guys a clip of their celebration
it's so cute I want to be lucky that's
what that made I'm happy yeah there's
that one white girl in there Georgia
Georgia just so you guys know look how
happy Honor
[Applause]
[Applause]
that seems like that's cool that they
always show a Nickelodeon or something
it seems to fun I know right you live in
the aged oh man where you know you know
back in the day these like Marvel and
like DC fellas they used to suck man
like they were terrible I don't remember
any
I remember the Hulk with what's called a
Lou Ferrigno is bad but now it's like
because of technology like you don't
have to imagine anything it's just like
the first Iron Man they're all okay like
I considered like Wonder Woman within
the whole everything else of and there's
only a few that's that got like Logan
Logan was just like a classic like that
we excited out what are you excited
about I'm excited about the fact that
like so when I first saw Wonder Woman
and I didn't realize like it was gonna
affect me the way Dave I kind of walked
out of that of the movie like to see a
woman and to see like a woman of color
and like such a true driving role she
was smart intelligent and she was really
grounded like they didn't make her to be
like the sexiest and they made the guy a
little [ __ ] which I thought was do you
saying it's the same effect because it's
music the black ledum
yeah yeah so it's like the same effect
for everyone else I would concede this
and like to relate to that like I'm
excited for everyone to feel that thing
I felt that from one split second in the
Wolverine The Wolverine one where he
fights his brother Sabretooth and then
the other guy comes with Daniel Henney
Oh Daniel having yeah - he's the guy
that with the two guns yes one Asian
superhero II don't remember that guy
that Asian guy he turns into a porcupine
[Laughter]
maybe we should make one need a real
agent down Nazi mother Marvel yellow
banana no I want a real make it dull you
could nobodies a villain yeah but he's a
dope as [ __ ] I know bud what's it called
[ __ ] a Wolverines lover Japanese
lover girl
the clawed lady she was McLeod lady yeah
she's dope though she's [ __ ] hot we
only have Green Lantern he didn't like a
Mortal Kombat character all of them is
so for our last story there was this
there's this twitch streamer he's super
famous or super popular uh he he goes by
doctor disrespect
oh nice wand you guys have heard of him
oh no what have you heard
so I know doctor disrespect because he
puts on a costume when he does his
twitches and he's very very popular and
I watched him before but I think
recently he did the Asian thing yeah so
so what happened so I'm going to show
you guys a clip of him a compilation of
him making these like racist jokes
towards Asian okay that's pretty [ __ ]
good oh my god
I will say that the first impression was
damn spot for a lot of people are [ __ ]
pissed about this though because they're
like saying that the intent behind it is
not like how when we did accents and so
yeah it's like let's laugh together like
it's like it's bothering things like
yeah he's mocking all the other players
and he's [ __ ] with the other so
accurate I know I know yeah and so
that's just stirring up some controversy
here yeah like it's just what Joe said
it's the intent but I just you know I
was kind of really surprised and it
wasn't the played out like a little dude
[ __ ] like this it's like he became
Vietnamese do respect a Vietnamese
person uh shit's crazy the whole point
kicked off the sandals underneath this
[ __ ] gaming table - you take off your
shoes were no [ __ ] goddamn reason
you're Asian as [ __ ] because I told you
right now I think the as a comic we
gotta give props to people who can mimic
something really really well
but as the public sees it you know how
like it's super sensitive these days
they don't want any white people making
any ethnic jokes just that's the bottom
line right but I think at the end of the
day it's all about intent yeah so I
think a lot of people are pissed because
they think that his intent was to
directly degrade whoever he's talking to
or whatever he's talking to someone
yeah but see I'm not for one I don't
know his content that well but I did
follow this and a lot of people are just
pissed off because of he's using culture
as like a low blow joke yeah right but
on the other hand I do understand gaming
and the the words that you use in gaming
you're you're just going in on crazy
like the craziest [ __ ] yeah you say some
crazy ass stuff but that's also a part
of gaming where you try to mess with the
minds of other people so you know but is
it right or wrong I don't know
I don't know the full context cuz he
wasn't speaking English at all so wasn't
like he was making fun of people's dick
size or like you know like you were
saying so it was just the accent was
just reciting hi kuzon vietnamese it's
so weird I'm so believable he said he's
so disgusting looking I know dude you
know then I guess dick smells like beer
yeah also is that a carrot that's a
character like it's like a stereotypical
like hillbilly character but that
mustache is his doll right cuz that's
not a fake mustache I thought it was not
too perfectly like no that's a character
he doesn't look like that but I think he
came up like real hard within a year on
Twitch and he has like mad viewers and
all that but I thought something
happened with him cheating on his wife
and like he has a wife yeah he had
previously been like streaming before
and then he ended up taking off his
disguise he confessed that he was
cheating on his wife and he was gonna
take time off the twitch to like focus
on his personal life but then he came
back you're getting gaming [ __ ] is what
he was doing
yeah then he came back smells like
Cheetos Oh God so Jimmy Wong he tweeted
out this compilation oh yeah Jimmy yeah
so he was the one that pointed out that
you know he's he's pretty racist
here and he also said this just like
dolt Logan Paul the reason this racist
behavior is unacceptable and dangerous
is simple young and extremely
impressionable kids adore these
influencers they learn their mannerisms
they copy them and they perpetuate them
between friends at school and at others
yeah that's sadly very true I think yeah
I do agree about like I do agree with
that because from an adult who
understands you know more about life and
people and culture we could probably
make those jokes and enjoy something
like a little more harsh but then 10
year olds 11 year old okay but like is
this character is that character like an
offensive character like is he always
offensive in his videos like that's his
thing that's his thing because that's
when I'm like well that's
they're all your kids already following
someone offensive words like the Logan
Paul thing he's like seeing as a
family-friendly brand who like broke the
brand that's like watching South Park
and saying hey why are you being racist
right yeah cuz like I mean I used to
listen to Eminem when I was growing up
and like he used to get tons of [ __ ]
from like people would be like he's you
know a bad influence and all this stuff
he's meant to be yeah that's this whole
persona that was like his whole Jam so
like if you're gonna listen to Eminem
you can't be like this is offensive and
keep listening to it like you can't do
that so I don't know it just to play
devil's advocate if it's an offensive
character that he's always offensive and
like everything he does is offensive I
don't really see that as being like out
of line yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz I always
think parents should control the content
not the content creator yeah content
creator should do what they do and of
course there's a there's a limit to like
if he was like staying crazy like but
what kill this person
yeah are like you know [ __ ] Chinese
people are like you know they had yeah
yeah I don't think I would have done a
better Vietnamese impression than him I
think that's gonna be off I've always
said that if people can do it well I
can't really get mad I it's like if he
did the ching chong ching chong fan i
would have been like all that shit's the
1980s man come on like but he was like
study is that why I like I don't know
it's just cuz it becomes a little more
relatable than cuz like if I heard
somebody say that at the corner of the
street right I would have just smooth it
out a while what the [ __ ] what a bit
nummies I thought I would have been like
an expat that lived in Vietnam or
something that's what it sounded like
[Music]
[Music]